rettungspaket für die lufthansa der bund
will bis zu neun milliarden euro geben
aber nur im notfall in die geschäfte
eingreifen schwere verwüstungen in asien
durch den wirbelsturm am kann sterben in
indien und bangladesch mehr als 80
menschen ein vatertag mit vernunft die
feiertags ausflügler haben sich
überwiegend an die korona regeln
gehalten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend herzlich
willkommen zu den heute nachrichten an
christi himmelfahrt das rettungspaket
für die lufthansa scheint so gut wie
beschlossen zu sein das bestätigte der
konzern in der nacht 9 milliarden euro
staatshilfe also steuergeld damit die
fluggesellschaft in folge der korona
krise nicht pleite geht inwieweit der
staat dafür an dem unternehmen beteiligt
wird und eine gewisse mitsprache erhält
war lange ein großer streitpunkt der
scheint jetzt ausgeräumt wie dominik
löschmeister berichtet fast die ganze
flotte am boden lange kann die lufthansa
den corona bedingten stillstand nicht
mehr verkraften
mit milliardenschweren staatshilfen will
die bundesregierung nun helfen das
rettungspaket beinhaltet ein kfw
darlehen über 3 milliarden euro hinzu
kommt eine direkte staatsbeteiligung von
20 prozent im notfall kann der bund
weitere fünf prozent plus eine aktie
übernehmen etwa um eine feindliche
übernahme zu verhindern
der staat hat natürlich auch ein klares
interesse wenn er so viel geld gibt und
mit 9 milliarden ist das ja sagen wir
der größte rettungsplan für ein
deutsches unternehmen
da ist es sicherlich zu erwarten auch
anders dem steuerzahler glaube ich nicht
zu erklären wenn man da nicht im
gegenzug auch ein gewisses
mitspracherecht bekommt mit 20 prozent
der aktien wäre der staat stärkste
anteilseigner würde zwei aufsichtsräte
besetzen eine sperrminorität hätte er
aber nur im notfall
so wie das aussieht wird der staat die
lufthansa stabilisieren ohne operativ
und strategisch ins geschäft
einzugreifen das ist genau der richtige
weg die gewerkschaft ufo begrüßt zwar
die staatshilfe kritisiert aber die
fehlende absicherung der mitarbeiter für
uns ist dieser einigung in der zumindest
eine arbeitsplatzsicherheit erstmal
nicht ersichtlich ist extrem
enttäuschend da hätte die politik
deutlich stärkere signale setzen können
und auch müssen wie wir finden auch
auflagen zum klimaschutz hat die
bundesregierung nicht gemacht neben
vorstand und aufsichtsrat muss auch eine
außerordentliche hauptversammlung der
staatshilfe noch zustimmen
also viele milliarden steuergeld für die
lufthansa aber ein mit
recht für den staat nur im notfall
stefan schlosser in frankfurt ist das
die lösung mit der die lufthansa gut
leben kann
ja es ist ein kompromiss ist zusagen
geben und nehmen aber die lufthansa
hätte damit zumindest ihr wichtigstes
ziel erreicht staatshilfe ja aber eben
keine staatliche geschäftsführung genau
dafür hat der vorstandschef carsten
spohr in der vergangenheit ja getrommelt
der staat solle sich aus dem operativen
geschäft heraushalten und könnte da
nicht anders als zum beispiel die
französische regierung bei der air
france in zukunft druck ausüben dass man
vielleicht nur noch europäische airbus
flugzeuge kauft dass man auf
inlandsflüge verzichtet oder dass man
nur noch bestimmte strecken fliegt dann
einen solchen wunschkatalog der wurde
auch schon von verschiedener seite in
deutschland formuliert zb dass der
hauptstadtflughafen wenn er dann endlich
mal fertig ist in zukunft mehr von der
lufthansa angeflogen wird
obwohl das vielleicht gar nicht
wirtschaftlich ist und genau über solche
fragen wird weiterhin allein die
konzernführung entscheiden im gegenzug
gibt es eben zwei staatliche aufseher im
aufsichtsrat die dividende wird wohl
gestrichen und die manager vergütung
angepasst das sind dann die kröten die
das unternehmen an der stelle zu
schlucken hat die einzelheiten von
stefan schlosser
vielen dank dafür nach frankfurt im
radio in zeitungen und im fernsehen ist
sie bereits verboten die tabakwerbung
jetzt plant die koalition weitere
werbeverbote darauf haben sich union und
spd nach langen verhandlungen
verständigt so soll außen reklame etwa
auf plakaten für herkömmliche zigaretten
ab 2022 verboten werden für e zigaretten
ab 2024
ungarn will seine umstrittenen
transitzonen für asylbewerber schließen
damit wolle man sich dem jüngsten urteil
des europäischen gerichtshofs beugen so
die regierung
in diesen zonen werden asylbewerber in
abgeschotteten container lagern
festgehalten
der bgh hatte diese unterbringung als
verstoß gegen eu-recht eingestuft die
bedingungen an der grenze zu serbien
glichen einer inhaftierung mitten in der
korona pandemie haben indien und
bangladesch nun auch noch mit einer
naturkatastrophe zu kämpfen
bei einem gewaltigen sturm sind
80 menschen ums leben gekommen und so
sah er aus der tropischen zyklon mit dem
namen am gestern traf er auf land und
zog dann über die grenzregion millionen
menschen hoffen in notunterkünften bald
zurück nach hause zu können wind und
regen haben aber viele orte verwüstet
julia schröter berichtet der morgen nach
dem zyklon am pannen auf land getroffen
ist die schäden lassen erahnen mit
welcher kraft er gebietet hat
zerstörungen wohin das auge blickt wir
haben jetzt viel zu tun wenn es solche
schweren schäden gibt ist es eine
schwierige aufgabe alles wieder
aufzubauen und es dauert die indische 15
millionenstadt kolkata ist erfüllt vom
geräusch der kettensägen aufräumen so
gut es geht auch damit elektriker sich
schnell an die stromversorgung machen
können
die in weiten teilen zusammengebrochen
ist der zyklon am panel wütete mit
spitzengeschwindigkeiten von 185
kilometern pro stunde brachte regen und
eine sturmflut
offizielle stellen hatten gewarnt eine
flutwelle könne mehr wasser bis zu 25
kilometer weit ins land spülen
die folgen auch zu sehen auf dem
flughafen von kolkata die küstenbewohner
trifft es am härtesten viele haben
praktisch alles verloren nicht nur in
indien sondern auch im nachbarland
bangladesch
wir haben uns in einem schutzraum in
sicherheit gebracht unser haus ist vom
sturm zerstört wir gehen zurück in unser
dorf um irgendwie unseren
lebensunterhalt zu verdienen
rund drei millionen menschen waren in
der region in notunterkünfte gebracht
worden
kein leichter schritt in corona zeiten
doch die gefahr durch den sturm war
größer eingeschätzt worden als das
ansteckungsrisiko
wie viele tote der zyklon gefordert hat
wird man in einigen tagen wissen ob sich
menschen in schutzräumen infiziert haben
das zeigt sich erst in ein paar wochen
viele informationen rund um das phänomen
wirbelsturm haben wir für sie online
zusammengestellt
zum beispiel wie zyklonen und hurricanes
entstehen und ein ausblick auf die
kommende wirbelsturmsaison nachzulesen
in der zdf- heute- app
besonders stark betroffen von der korona
pandemie ist brasilien erstmals gab es
innerhalb von 24 stunden fast 20.000
neue infektionen auch in der kroner
notfallstation am berühmten maracana
stadion steigt die zahl der patienten
täglich allerdings so klagen ärzte gebe
es zu wenig medikamente und
beatmungsgeräte insgesamt sind in
brasilien mehr als 200 91.000 menschen
infiziert fast 19.000 sind gestorben
schauen wir nach belarus früher
weißrussland in ein land das einen sehr
eigenwilligen corona weg geht
langzeitherrscher lukaschenko schlug
alle warnungen der whu der
weltgesundheitsorganisation in den wind
und verzichtete auf beschränkungen des
öffentlichen lebens so gab es etwa
weiter fußballspiele mit publikum und
auch die traditionelle sieges parade zum
ende des zweiten weltkriegs aber corona
ist auch in belarus angekommen christian
sinn im leben von svetlana stadtkewitz
ging es bislang vor allem um schönheit
doch in den letzten wochen nee die
visagistin und ehemalige
schönheitskönigin nur noch schutzmasken
und anzüge auch firma rohde
krankenhäuser als die krankenhäuser in
den sozialen netzwerken gesehen haben
dass sich masken produziere haben sie
mich gefragt ob ich auch anzüge für die
mediziner nähen kann die menschen in
belarus sind verwirrt einerseits kann
eine ausgangssperre auch geschäfte
bleiben offen
andererseits rät das
gesundheitsministerium zu schutzmasken
handschuhen und selbstisolation und von
ganz oben wurde die gefahr bislang
verleugnet von staatschef alexander
lukaschenko immer wieder bezeichnet als
letzter diktator europas
am 9 mai noch gab es zum gedenken an das
kriegsende vor 75 jahren eine
militärparade und gegen korona helfe
wodka sauna und traktorfahren hier gibt
es kein virus oder sehen sie als
rumfliegen ich jedenfalls nicht das ist
hier wie ein kühlschrank die kälte und
der sport sind das beste mittel gegen
das virus
währenddessen verbreitet sich das virus
mehr als 30.000 infizierte und 179 tote
diese offiziellen zahlen zweifeln viele
hier an die situation wird immer
komplizierter weil die
quarantänemaßnahmen zu wünschen übrig
lassen
sie reichen nicht aus heute hat sich
lukaschenko wieder zu corona geäußert
ein sinneswandel
er sagt man müsse um das leben der
menschen kämpfen und dürfen nicht
lockerlassen wohl kein zufall
heute ist offizieller wahlkampfauftakt
in belarus im august sind
präsidentschaftswahlen
die zahl der weltweit registrierten
corona fälle hat die marke von fünf
millionen überschritten
das geht aus den daten der johns hopkins
universität hervor hier in deutschland
haben sich fast 100 79.000 menschen mit
dem virus infiziert davon gelten rund
100 58.000 als genesen
8195 menschen sind im zusammenhang mit
cupid 19 gestorben
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich täglich 620 menschen neu
angesteckt auch christi himmelfahrt war
heute von den chor ohne regeln geprägt
der bundesweite feiertag wird immer 40
tage nach ostern begangen
bei sommerlichen temperaturen konnten
viele der traditionellen gottesdienste
im freien stattfinden
himmelfahrt ist aber auch vatertag dazu
treffen sich eigentlich jahr für jahr
männer mit bier und bollerwagen
schwierig in kroner zeiten wie die
menschen in hamburg den feiertag nutzen
berichtet jetzt stefan wachs stadt
bollerwagen eine bootsfahrt viele
hamburger und tagestouristen nutzten den
tag eher anders um wiedergewonnene
freiheiten zu genießen zum beispiel für
eine hafenrundfahrt jetzt wieder möglich
wenn auch mit einschränkungen auch
draußen auf dem oberdeck ein bisschen
besser verteilen meisten pflicht und
mindestabstand die schiffe daher nur
halb besetzt
wir haben gleich drei tage hamburg
kommen man muss ja endlich mal raus
bei dem wetter vor allen dingen
unbedingt der vorteil muss man ja auch
sagen es ist nicht so voll auf den
schiffen ungewohnt leer auch eine andere
attraktion das miniatur wunderland statt
1000 jetzt nur 200 besucher zeitgleich
erlaubt und die müssen eine extra wunder
länder straßenverkehrsordnung beachten
weil wir gemerkt wir haben eng stellen
wir haben teilweise richtig platz haben
und wir müssen die leute dazu bringen
dass sie sich nicht auf dieses rege
konzentrieren können sondern auf die
anlage
spontane besucher heute selten deshalb
keine wartezeiten die meisten hatten
einen termin gebucht und die tour
geplant
ich war immer vatertag mit den kindern
weg und wenn wir am sonntag gelesen das
haben wir schon offen ist dass man hier
schon ein bisschen das unternehmen kann
grillen im stadtpark allerdings verboten
auch picknick wichtig die zahl 10 so
viele menschen aus zwei haushalten
durften sich in einer gruppe treffen
laut polizei hielten sich auch die
meisten heute an die regeln
viele polnische pendler wollen den
feiertag offenbar für ein verlängertes
wochenende nutzen
die folge an der grenze haben sich
wieder lange staus gebildet
auf der a4 bei görlitz standen die autos
und lkw wegen der polnischen
grenzkontrollen auf über 40 kilometern
auf der a12 bei frankfurt an der oder
sogar auf mehr als 50 kilometern zum
fußball auch die saison der dritten liga
soll zu ende gespielt werden das
entschied der dfb und legte den 30 mai
als termin für den neustart fest und in
der ersten bundesliga will wolfsburg
seine negativserie gegen dortmund
beenden anja fröhlich seit sechs spielen
hat wolfsburg gegen den bvb keinen
treffer mehr erzielt
der 2 1 sieg gegen augsburg am
vergangenen samstag gibt zwar
selbstvertrauen
dennoch gegen den zweiten der liga gegen
dortmund muss sich die mannschaft von
trainer claas nach steigern
ich denke einfach dass wir absoluter
funktion obersten level agieren müssen
um überhaupt eine chance zu haben gegen
dortmund
die lust am spiel ist bei den
dortmundern derzeit sehr ausgeprägt
sinnbild hierfür der stürmerstar auf
norwegen holland im ruhrderby gegen
schalke gab es eine schwarz-gelbe
machtdemonstration 1 4 0 der höchste
derby-sieg seit 1966
geht es nach lucien favre so soll der
tabellenzweite auch auswärts drei punkte
holen denn die dortmunder wollen
weiterhin erster bayern jäger bleiben
was kostet ein echter picasso eine frau
aus italien brauchte nur 100 euro los
und eine große portion glück und dieses
werk war iris eine zeitung und ein
absinth glas zeigen die pinselstriche
des spanischen meisters schätzwert eine
million euro
insgesamt kamen durch den losverkauf
mehr als fünf millionen euro zusammen
davon geht eine an den alten besitzer
der rest fließt in hilfsprojekte eine
aktion für den guten zweck und für die
glückliche gewinnerin ein picasso zum
schnäppchenpreis
und wir haben noch das wetter morgen
ziehen von westen her kompakte wolken
auf und es regnet anfangs nur wenig
später heftiger und teils begleitet von
blitz und donner
ganz im süden bleibt es überwiegend
trocken bei 15 bis 29 grad
so viel von uns für heute christian
sievers erwartet sie um 10 18 zum
heute-journal und barbara hahlweg freut
sich morgen auf sie um 19 uhr
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit einer doku
über sansibar einen schönen rest
feiertag und auf wiedersehen